pourtant hier soir Emmanuel Macron a dit
souhaiter que la réforme puisse aller au
bout de son cheminement démocratique
dans le respect de tous que dites-vous
on a tous eu je crois lors des repas de
famille ce petit gamin de 5 ans qui
avait cassé son jouet et qui voulait
absolument qu'ici a gripper qui hurlait
qui n'entendait pas raison c'est un peu
la définition des manuels
il a pondu une réforme immature
illogique malfagoté et injuste et alors
que tout le monde lui dit que cette
réforme n'est pas bonne même ceux
d'ailleurs qui voudrait un durcissement
des règles il s'y agrippe c'est son
totem c'est son doudou il veut aller
jusqu'au bout bouffi d'orgueil
probablement et absent dans son esprit
avec l'absence dans son esprit du sens
de l'intérêt général ce président de la
République c'est emmuré lui-même dans la
forteresse qu'il a construit il est
isolé seul avec un gouvernement à la
botte avec d'ailleurs des personnalités
assez faibles qui supportent les
diktates quotidiens du président et puis
avec un reniement du Parlement tout ça
ne peut pas durer bien longtemps
sur le texte un vote sur le texte issu
des conclusions de la commission de
l'expéritaire oui au Sénat avec des
sénateurs LR qui sont plus macronistes
que Macron lui-même qui ont fait du fait
d'aller à la soupe une espèce de
doctrine je crois qu'ils sont très
décalés de leur électorat et que si
aujourd'hui la candidate à la
présidentielle DLR a fait 4 % c'est
parce qu'ils ont trahi à peu près tout
leur tout leur toute leur doctrine et
tout ce en quoi ils croyaient
[Musique]